et notre invité politique savatan c'est
hervé marseille bonjourbonjour beaucoup
vu naître avec nous au sénateur des
hauts-de-seine président du groupe union
centriste
ici au sénat on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale et
on retrouve avec plaisir julien lécuyer
bonjour julien bonjour aux lionnes vont
entrer mais on est
je viens de la voix du nord c'est ça
vous représente pour pour cette nouvelle
saison même si évidemment tout le monde
vous connaît un peu marseille on va
commencer en parlant du conseil national
de la refondation s'est lancé ce matin
par emmanuel macron pourquoi refuser par
principe d'y participer
d'abord on n'était pas invité à chercher
une invitation hier donc à ces gentils
de m'interroger mais on n'était pas
invité d'ailleurs en effet voilà voilà
voilà c'est pour ça je préfère rester
avec vous ce matin et donc
pourquoi ne pas y aller d'abord encore
une fois un on n'était pas invité deux
tout le monde l'a dit parmi ceux qui ont
refusé comme le président larcher c'est
que il ya déjà des institutions gars le
parlement il ya le cse qui a été réformé
le conseil économique social et
environnemental qui a été réformé en
2021 justement pour avoir ce type
deux débats et puis quand on voit le
parlement on voit de tout le monde est
représenté au parlement il ya 89 députés
rassemblement national il ya 75 députés
les filles et vers la droite bon alors
pourquoi créer quelque chose à côté on a
l'impression qu'on veut éviter le
parlement
revivifiée revivent ici à la démocratie
quand je cite
l'exécutif via des des nouvelles formes
de dialogue ça vous inspire pas mais
enfin de toute façon quoi qui se passe
c'est au parlement qu'il qu'il reviendra
de voter des textes bon et je vois pas
que vous gardez tout vos prérogatives
pourquoi ne pas discuter en amont
c'est pas parce qu'on va se réunir à
marcoussis sympathiquement autour d'un
café
que va trouver des solutions comme ça en
cinq minutes je veux dire les débats
parlementaires à quoi sert-il ont fait
nous aussi de la concertation les
commissions parlementaires à quoi elles
servent et passent leurs journées à
faire des auditions avec les mêmes qui
participent à la convention de la
refondation qu'il ya des précédents
convention citoyenne le grand débat
enfin tout ça est restée lettre morte
qu'on vend le grand débat souvenez vous
on allait voir ce qu'on allait voir
c'était sacré on aller numériser les et
les cahiers des états généraux de
doléances dans toutes les bibliothèques
de france ça dort dans des cartons je ne
sais où la convention citoyenne c'était
sacré il fallait des modifier la
constitution de touchant à rien c'était
du concentré de démocratie c'est parti
je ne sais zouk bon et maintenant on
nous parle de refondation parce que
c'était une promesse du président
pendant les élections présidentielles
bon franchement je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de doutes et de réserve on
verra bien mais la politique de la
chaise vide est ce que ça fait avancer
les dossiers mais c'est encore une fois
chez id par rapport à quoi s'il ya des
attentes c'est pas pour qu'on discute il
ya des attentes pour qu'on donne des
solutions aujourd'hui on a des problèmes
internationaux
qu'on paye la crise une chrétienne
sur le plan énergétique les piscines
ferme c'est là que les gens maintenant
on en parle plus de choses qu'on montre
sur des cartes on leur dit pas où ça va
on se bat là-bas on est là bas là c'est
chez eux tous les jours c'est la copro
qui dit voilà la facture d'électricité
c'est les gosses qui vont plus à la
piscine ces soucis du quotidien pour les
français donc des attentes des solutions
pas des bavoirs terme de combats en fait
emmanuel macron selon vous ou en tout
cas il se trompe de priorité je suis pas
cette technique qui consiste à chaque
fois et
éviter les institutions les enceintes
parlementaires les représentations pour
créer des bidules
dont on sait pas très bien qui a comment
ça se passe quel est l'ordre du jour
enfin c'est
ça va être un vrai problème dans la
relation entre senna et exécutif que non
cnr existe écoutez le président il a la
liberté de réunir qui veut donc c'est
plus on a la liberté de voter ce qu'on
veut mais c'est pas gênant de voir les
associations d'élus locaux
ti pa association des maires de france y
participer et les sénateurs s'abstenir
écoutez les associations ils ont leur
responsabilité au départ et voulait pas
y aller et puis président les a reçus
personnellement la main sur le coeur ils
ont qu'on allait en faire une grande loi
de décentralisation il ya besoin de
faire un ses nerfs pour dire qu'on va
faire une loi de décentralisation
ils vont parler chacun facile en voilà
et puis j'espère qu'il y aura
effectivement cette grande loi de
décentralisation
oui petite petite question sur aussi la
cette rentrée cette rentrée que vous
avez qualifié de baroque vous dites on
éteint les incendies après les uns après
les autres mais il n'y a pas de ligne
politique on est complètement dans le
flou seul vous écouter
j'ai entendu ce que disait la première
ministre quand dans sa déclaration de
politique générale bon depuis on pas
très bien quelle est quelle est la ligne
les premiers textes que nous avons à
étudier ici au sénat c'est
l'indemnisation du chômage mais d'un
côté on fait des concertations large ses
nerfs voilà et là on dit ah bah non on
va régler les problèmes par décret tu
parles d'une concertation six syndicats
et patronat n'arrive pas à un accord qui
peut probable on est d'accord la messe
est dite
ensuite vous avez la loppsi
vous voterez loi sécurité je sais pas
c'est passé en conseil des ministres on
va étudier les textes c'est assez
longtemps enclins à voter oui mais c'est
assez déclaratif teyon fenua sécurité
puis dedans il ya quoi y'a qu'à 15
milliards oui mais à 15 milliards et une
augmentation des effectifs
gendarmes qui avaient des choses et des
choses on va dire qu'il rien mais
puisque je veux dire c'est beaucoup plus
à usage politique et cosmétiques que des
problèmes de fond
donc avec vous ça évite complètement le
débat de fond et 8500 policiers jean
doubler les aînés à chaque fois c'est
pas cosmétiques on peut maintenant mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que à chaque
fois c'est toujours un peu plus quoi de
cet été il y avait des incendies il
fallait dire un peu plus d'avions un peu
plus de pompier l'a un peu plus policier
très bien on va mettre plus de policiers
mais c'est pas que ça il ya un problème
sur la justice on voit bien que vous
pouvez pas parler de sécurité si vous
parlez pas de justice il ya le problème
des mineurs
il ya tout un ensemble de sujets mais
ces sites une loi que dans la bonne
direction mais vous auriez aimé qu'elle
aille plus loin plus on simplement les
débats permettront d'essayer de
globaliser davantage il y aura les
problèmes de l'immigration ce qui
j'espère viendront un peu plus tard qui
devait venir d'ailleurs en cette rentrée
c'est ce que gérald darmanin avait
promis avant était finalement c'est
reporter vous le regrettez
j'espère que ça viendra parce que c'est
un vrai sujet n'est sans doute comment
vous en doutez non mes joueurs pour
l'instant ça traîne on nous annonce des
débats là encore de bavardage des
échanges mais les textes tarde à venir
le ministre visiblement souhaité écuyer
un texte le gouvernement et plus
réticents je patiente dans la majorité
tout le monde voit sur cette ligne donc
ça veut dire vous craignez un recul
il va y avoir le budget budget social
budget de la nation donc j'espère que ça
viendra en début de l'année prochaine la
majorité relative obtenue par le
président robin un petit peu les cartes
au niveau parlementaire et voire même or
si tu redonnes de l'importance au sénat
où on voit le gouvernement qui réfléchit
beaucoup plus à passer devant les
sénateurs avant d'aller à l'assemblée
nationale c'est une bonne chose non mais
c'est la toujours été important il s'en
était pas rendu compte suffisamment est
donc aujourd'hui mais oui parce que
les temps
étaient dans wii et puis je pense que
c'est un travail qui fait un travail de
qualité on va au fond des choses il ya
une expérience qui n'est peut-être pas
toujours à l'assemblée avec des députés
assez récent donc je pense que c'est une
bonne chose que maintenant l'exécutif
travailler avec le sénat a parlé de
bouteilles oui parce que le projet de
loi de finances s'annonce compliquée une
ministre du budget gabriel attal a
appelé ce qu'il appelle ce qu'il a nommé
le dialogue de bercy y êtes vous
favorable ou est ce que comme eric
ciotti vous estimez que les
parlementaires n'ont pas vocation à être
la béquille du gouvernement était
d'abord moi je suis pas candidat à la
présidence des verts donc
c'est eric ciotti la responsabilité de
ses propos et de ses choix non
est ce que les centristes ont vocation à
y aller oui oui je veux dire
il s'agite pas on peut pas à la fois
dire il faut de la concertation avec
l'exécutif travaille avec le parlement
et quand on nous propose d'échanger
ne pas y aller vous décidez d'y aller
mais pas con pas aux séries parce que
c'est laisser le
dialogue normal entre le gouvernement et
les parlementaires il faut que ce soit
dans un cas ça s'est toujours fait comme
ça c'est dans le cadre institutionnel
que le ministre du budget il s'agit pas
de co construire le budget on n'est pas
dans la majorité on n'est pas au
gouvernement il s'agit d'échanger sur
les propositions et de dire écoutez ça
ça nous voit où ça nous va moins bien et
nous vous proposons telle était la
motivation c'est des changes normal qui
a systématiquement est-ce que du coup
vous allez dialoguer on a compris mais
est ce que vous pourriez voter ce budget
selon ce qu'il en sort ou est-ce que par
principe nous dit on est dans la
position allongée ça se décide pas sans
savoir ce qui est dans ce qu'on va vous
était donc
temps mais quel texte celui qui aura été
modifié par le sénat ou celui du
gouvernement enfin bon voilà d'habitude
il nous est arrivé souvent de voter le
budget au sénat mais c'était celui qu'on
avait demandé nous mêmes bon on va voir
entraîner 49,3 sur le budget écoutez je
trouve je trouve un peu
gênant moi je suis je suis gêné par le
fait que d'un côté encore une fois on
passe son temps par les dialogues des
changes de concertation et la première
ministre qui vient dix ans de toute
façon pour le budget c'est 49,3 circulez
ya plus rien à voir
fier qu'on connaît la fin du film avant
d'avoir vu le film a dit ça parce que
les
photos c'est compliqué d'abord faire des
économies d'énergie on peut peut-être
fermer le parlement comme ça il y aura
rien à chauffer pendant quelques
semaines mais je veux dire franchement
il ya il ya un débat institutionnel
chaque année qui est l'acte le plus
important c'est le budget c'est celui
qui marque les majorités 1 donc c'est
normal que la france insoumise comme les
républicains annonce qu' ils sont pas
prêts à rentrer dans la majorité c'est
leur choix c'est clairement mais non
parce qu'il ya un budget qu'on va
regarder ce qu'il ya dedans va regarder
ce qu'il ya dedans et selon ce cadre
vous pourriez aller voter au revoir
c'est vrai moi j'ai bien au delà de ça
c'est vrai que les oppositions en
réponse aux 49 3 parle de dissolution
est ce que a de la même façon je crois
que c'était mathilde de panneaux qui le
disait il ya une sorte de compte à
rebours vers la dissolution là aussi
c'est une crainte
c'est une épée de damoclès on sait
depuis les élections législatives qu'il
n'y a pas de majorité et que si un
incident de parcours il peut y avoir une
dissolution c'est la prérogative du
président de la république s'il juge le
parlement n'est plus en situation de
travail et il a toujours la possibilité
de dissoudre bon je ne le souhaite pas
parce que ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
revoter je suis pas sûr que le moment
soit le lieu choisi
il faut faire en sorte que les choses
avancent et pour ça que si on peut
travailler intelligemment avec bercy et
discuter le budget dont le flanc et un
débat sur la taxation des supers profits
elle est maniable
à une contribution au niveau européen
que ça ne faisait pas ça sera au niveau
national vous vous nous aviez parlé de
cette idée ans était déjà avant l'été
vous êtes favorable est-ce que ça c'est
un point de désaccord et les
républicains jusqu'à présent oui
je pense je pense que c'est une erreur
c'est l'expérience montre que jour après
jour il ya de plus en plus de
parlementaires qui viennent à l'idée je
pense que c'est une erreur politique
parce que socialement c'est quand même
compliqué d'expliquer d'un côté qu'il y
a des gens à qui on demande des efforts
et de l'autre côté on peut pas aider les
entreprises quand elles vont mal comme
on l'a fait pendant la corrida la sur
les problèmes énergétiques en 2008 comme
l'a fait nicolas sarkozy qui banques
quand il y avait les difficultés
financières en europe et puis quand
elles vont bien dire ah bah on va leur
faire confiance c'est des braves gens
ils vont sûrement augmenter les salaires
et ils vont contribuer franchement la
fiscalité c'est la sphère de l'état dans
un pays comme le nôtre dans une
démocratie
la fiscalité c'est l'état et donc c'est
à l'état de dire qui doit payer l'impôt
et comment ils l'auraient partie et
c'est le parlement qui vote c'est pas le
ministre qui vient au parlement en
disant on va leur demander s'ils veulent
bien faire des efforts à la pompe ou
jaune saison mais alors vous allez leur
proposer dans le cadre du dialogue de
bercy et la république en fait une
erreur politique je pense qu'ils avaient
tous ceux qui le font votre pas y
compris le gouvernement font une erreur
politique dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative vous aviez
également soutenu l'aide aux
collectivités territoriales pour faire
face à la crise énergétique j'allais
dire l'annoncent d'un fonds vert ça
devrait plutôt vous satisfaire oui mais
je pense que c'est pas satisfaisant
totalement sait bien qui est ce joueur
je pense qu'on voit bien que la
fermeture des piscines dans beaucoup de
communes qui est un problème coût de
l'énergie qui augmente considérablement
et donc il ya un vrai sujet et donc nous
nous avions de façon un peu prémonitoire
proposer le bouclier tarifaire communal
c'est à dire que quand le le coût de
l'énergie augmenté sur les trois années
précédentes sur une moyenne des trois
années précédentes de plus de 20% au nom
d al etat d'abonder à 50% de ce coût
supplémentaire je pense qu'il faut
revoir ce dispositif revenir à la charge
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de communes qui
ne vont pas pouvoir chauffer les
piscines les patinoires les gymnases
régime menacé énorme quand vous en avez
plusieurs dans une ville ça demande une
énergie folle il va falloir avoir
véritable ligne de conduite sur ces
sujets voyez qu'en californie par
exemple maintenant on ne peut plus
recharger les batteries de voitures
électriques à toutes les heures il ya
des horaires choisis lors d'un côté on
vous dit il faut des voitures
électriques de l'autre côté on vous dit
oui mais vous pouvez recharger vos
batteries contre taylor et l heure il ya
un vrai sujet donc il faut que l'état
intervienne fasse des choix avec les
collectivités et il faut qu'on ait une
véritable
discussion pour savoir maintenant
quelles sont les priorités on ne pourra
plus tout faire comme avant la
constitutionalisation interruption
volontaire de grossesse revient dans le
débat notamment ici au sénat il ya une
proposition là qui est porté par la
sénatrice écologiste mélanie vogel est
ce que vous la voix trop non pourquoi
pourquoi parce que la constitution
moi je suis assez fatigué je suis
favorable et fidèles à ben ali lui sont
favorables à ce qu'a fait si mode veille
et il faut le protéger c'est un acquis
pour les femmes ceci étant dit je pense
que la constitution peut pas tout les 5
minutes dire tiens au fait la convention
citoyenne a inventé un truc à il ya pour
lui et j'ai là c'est pour il faut
sacralisé telle et telle chose c'est pas
une brocante un la constitution on vient
pas tous les jours avec
quelque chose qu'on veut sacralisé il ya
je ne sais combien de dizaines voire de
centaines de propositions pour modifier
la constitution
j'ai une constitution ça doit être court
on doit y toucher d'une main tremblante
suivant la formule consacrée et est-ce
que et donc je pense que
même pour les vg je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on touche à la
constitution
oui et qui traverse quelques turbulences
après la mise le placement en garde à
vue de jean christophe lagarde votre
président hier matin après avoir été
interpellé à son domicile dans le cadre
de l' affaire concernant les fausses
accusations qui ont visité les deux
députés insoumis rachel garrido et
alexis corbière est-ce que vous avez un
commentaire par rapport à ces affaires
n'ont d'abord j'ai des pensées amicales
pour lui et sa famille parce que c'est
un ami et ça reste un ami au contraire
j'ai pas l'habitude de lâcher mes amis
quand ils sont dans la difficulté
il est sorti semble-t-il de garde à vue
et aucune charge n'a été retenue contre
lui donc
je tienne comme aime à le préciser est
sorti de garde à vue ce matin il m'a mis
un message cette nuit et donc il est
sorti sans aucune charge bon et tant
mieux ce qu'est ce qui nous a dit on pas
que ce soir j'étais très très elliptique
à une ruée sortie il à dire voilà j'ai
pu m'expliquer rien n'a été retenu
contre moi alors après son affaire
l'oqaj pas au courant
sur le plan politique il avait décidé
dès le mois de juin de prendre du recul
et de ne plus assumer de responsabilités
et j'avais été désigné président délégué
le 21 juin à l'occasion d'un bureau
politique donc voilà j'allais dire lui
il a décidé de de s'occuper de sa
défense de ses problèmes de se refaire
si je puis dire après sa défaite aux
législatives
c'est toujours un moment pénible et donc
il est avec les ses proches et
voilà il est alors comment va se passer
la suite pour paul et lui dise qu'on a
eu un calendrier pour en congrès on va
faire le point nous nous réunissons à
reims à partir de ce soir jusqu'à samedi
moi je suis en liaison avec jean louis
borloo qui est puisqu'on va fêter les 10
ans de la création de lui dit et donc il
reste l'inspirateur du mouvement pour
voir l'orientation il devait venir je
suis pas sûr qu'il puisse venir parce
que devait partir à l'étranger
il va essayer
pour autant nous notre ligne c'est une
ligne d'autonomie et d'indépendance
quand on voit les difficultés qu'il y a
dans le monde politique actuel quand on
voit les difficultés qui risquent
d'apparaître au plan parlementaire voire
législatives s'il doit y avoir une
dissolution
nous nous souhaitons d'avoir un rester
unis bien sûr puisque nous avons une
organisation territoriale qui est à nos
points forts et puis
nous souhaitons à partir de la conserver
cette ligne d'indépendance et
d'autonomie
mais juste sur l'organisation pour qu'on
soit clair donc jean christophe lagarde
après dur que vous avez dit il ne sera
plus président de l'unps et meurt devant
le prochain congrès est ce que vous vous
avez vocation à devenir officiellement
coûté j'en parlais avec ceux qui
m'entourent au bureau politique je ferai
partie de la direction mais il ya
valérie létard il ya christophe tegelen
députés tous les deux ont été désigné
porte-parole qui aura une élection oui
il y aurait une haie mais vous vous
donnez encore un petit peu de temps pour
être réglé lundi salam on va en parler
ce week end et on va régler les
problèmes
non je n'ai pas fixé mais d'ici la fin
de l'année mais on est d'accord d'ici la
fin de l'année comme chez les verts
on ne va pas
le prochain président des républicains
écoutez j'ai beaucoup de sympathie et
d'amitié et bruno et qui on travaille
tous les jours moi je ne me mêle pas des
affaires des républicains voilà
républicains ils ont la liberté de
choisir leur ligne la liberté mais vous
pouvez estimer que le choix qu'ils
feront une certaine une certaine
influence sur l'avenir de vos relations
est ce que vous préférez quand même un
avenir avec bruno retailleau à la tête
de la dlr plutôt qu'avec eric ciotti
mais encore une fois c'est pas c'est pas
à nous de choisir
le responsable hervé morin s'est
prononcé par exemple c'est eric ciotti
ciotti c'est fini l'alliance interdit je
m'interdis de faire part de mes
appréciations sur les élections au sein
de l air et
soit le président ça ne changera rien
dans les autre chose ça changera quelque
chose en la liant sur la droite mais
c'est un problème de ligne politique
c'est pas un problème d'homme c'est à
dire alors posons la question
différemment s'il a les républicains se
droitise encore est-ce que ça remettra
en cause votre relation avec le parti
dans mais les élections au sein de nerfs
concerne heller après les conséquences
et concerne tout le monde pourquoi parce
qu'il ya des alliances jusqu'à présent
vous regardez dans les régions il ya des
alliances et l'érudit pour garder dans
les départements c'est des alliances et
les rebelles après au
sénat et une majorité
pour la présidentielle
c'était un candidat de la droite et du
centre choisi par la droite puisque nous
ont été priés de regarder par la fenêtre
et je veux dire on n'a pas le droit
d'aller voter donc
voilà j'ai dit il ya une tendance quand
même eux
à l'introspection sheller
qui crée forcément des conséquences soit
il ya une ligne qui appellent au
rassemblement
soit on constate qu' il n'y a pas de
possibilité quand j'entends les uns et
les ans des preuves d'amour quoi en fait
maintenant mais j'attends de savoir
quelle est leur ligne politique quand
j'ai écouté hier parce qu'il a peu parlé
pour l'instant eric ciotti j'entends
bien qu'il est plutôt sur une ligne bas
nous on veut faire un parti de droite
et
que les centristes et ceux qui ceux qui
se sentent proches du centre face en
gros il faut refaire rpr udf ouais voilà
et après peut peut-être faire des
alliances mais faut refaire rpr udf vous
êtes d'accord avec ça est-ce que l'udps
et a vocation à devenir indépendant à
être indépendant est ce que vous avez
occasion avoir approché d'elle ou à vous
rapprocher des manuels macro est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes clairement dans
l'opposition on est dans l'opposition on
travaille et que la majorité dans
l'intérêt du pays sur les textes qui
nous sont proposés puisqu'il vous
l'avais dit il ya une configuration en
parlementaire qui appelle à la
responsabilité et puis on va attendre de
connaître la ligne des républicains
aujourd'hui moi je ne sais pas quelle
est la ligne des uns et des autres et je
sais même pas qui va être candidat
puisqu'il vous parler de deux candidats
il y en a peut-être d'autres je sais pas
ce que ça va donner parce qu'il ya un
1er mai un deuxième tour aussi et donc
on verra bien ce que tout ça donne mais
hans nous on se prononcera le moment
venu en fonction de la ligne mais on
s'en mêle pas merci à marseille c'est
très clair merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin
[Musique]